Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier,
and welcome back to Depth.
Now, I've calmed down a bit.
I have, stepped back from my bitchous nature and I have reassumed my own bravery.
Those were all fancy words to mean absolutely dick because I didn't do none of those things,
I'm just saying that I feel a little better than I have before,
and I'm gonna do the tutorial to show how to do a shark and then
I'm gonna try to play a shark, and then I'm gonna try to be a shark
And that's gonna be the way that I do this thing and I have no idea  I HATE THE FUCKING OCEAN
I hate this game.
Anyways, so, I'm gonna try to learn how to try to play,
and then I'm gonna try to be a shark in a multiplayer match
which hopefully will be a little less terrifying for me.
Oh god, is this Captain Doucher Nutter?
Oh yes please tell me about how my life is less valuable than your treasure. Uh huh.
Yes, go on. Oh yeah. Oh fuck you.
(Captain) *so, You want to be a treasure hunter?*
Not any more
(Captain) *We've got a mission to do, so this is a perfect timing*
Okay!
(Captain) *Alright... before i send you down there, let's get you outfitted*
Why don't you have an arm!? Oh, I know how to do this. Oh, I don't have enough money.
(Captain) *That's a good pistol. Russian hardware, very nice*
Okay.. That's a pistol alright! Alright, thanks, alright.
I'm ready. Ready
(Captain) *You all set? There's a treasure out there, so let's get going*
There's a treasure out th- Oh god!
You mean by "let's" get going, you mean, I get going and you stay on the boat with one arm
WHY DO YOU HAVE ONE ARM?! WHY?! TELL ME WHY?!
Ain't nothin' but a heart break...
ok sure alright then
oah gotta aim
(Captain) *If a shark attacks, i'm trusting you to keep him in one piece*
*random markimoo noises*
what about me, can I be in one piece? I like being in one piece
oh god (jumpscare)
Ah fucking god damn it
Fuck you
Fuck this mission fuck everything about this shit
why are the sharks in this universe so... verial is not the right word
versatile is not either
VISCOUS, that's the word
not verial and versatile
I don't know, they're probably reproducing a whole lot
Ahhh..
*Mark is fear*
Oh! Ok And th- ohh a golden gun
Is this golden eye with the golDAN gun?
Ooook Alright
Uhhhh
AHHH
hate this..
oohh I hate this
ooohh hate... hate...hate 3x
goldan gun
ok alright
I'm just doing. Wh- there's more? Okayy
Ih just keeps re-appearing
Wooow
I am LOADAD up
haBUH
(Captain) *Great work, we'll split the profit and you can buy some better gear for your next dive*
WHY DO WE SPLIT THE PROFIT?! WHEN I'M GRABBING IHHHTT
"Get your knife out to move faster" *reading*
Oooh okay
Come back S.T.E.V.E!
Take this! Oooah shit
I fucked that up
Ooohh
Fuckk
Whhoops
Alright. Hang on
Gotta ARCH IT!
Nooope
That didn't work
Hiyaduusky
Okay gottt it!
Go faster will youhh
Everyone knows you move faster with a knife BRUH
Everyone- ohh f*ck
I don't wanna do this..
I don't wanna do this!
I'D RATHER HAVE MY GUN OUT FOR WHEN I GET ATTackkeedd
*quietly* fucking fucking fuck- *gasp*
*continues* fucking fucking fucking shit
fuck *crescendo* fuck fuck 4x
Ooohhh boy
OOOh boy
Please don't kill me
I like life...
(Captain) *This is not on the map... toss a flare down there for me, we might find some more treasure*
Ok, alright! I will do that boss!
For YOUUUUU
THAT DID NOT HELP! It just looks like Blooooooohhh
AHHH!
OOHH BOY AIYAII!
Fucking
FUUUCKING
FUCKKKK
DIEEE!
hOly shit OW!
(Captain) *The shark was relentless, but you show him who's the boss*
WHAT ABOUT MY LEGS?!
I SEEM TO BE QUITE DABBLAGED
(Captain) *I tell all my divers the same thing. "Buy flares, the ocean is a dark place." you never know when you will need a bit of light*
Hahhhhh
Yeah..
Yeah. About that
Yeah. Ohh so fuck you
Also, what is this placeee
(Captain) *This is it... i knew pirates have used this area to store the treasure*
uhh.. *Mark is worried*
(Captain) *Damn! The lock rusted shut. It's going to take S.T.E.V.E a bit to get this open. Keep him covered*
Oh suree it will
Oh okay yeahh alright ooohhhh OKAY
I'M GONNA DIEEEE!
I'VE GOT LIKE 2 HEALTHH
(Captain) *Looks like he took a bite of you, go patch yourself up*
YEAH!
MAYBE A LITTLE BIT!
MAYBE A LITTLE BIT OF A BITE
YEAH
LET'S CALL IT A BITE
LET'S CALL IT NOT MY WHOLE LEG BEING REMOVED
OH!
TH- THAT'LL FIX IT
OH JUST AN INJECTION
A LITTLE BANDAID! THAT'LL WORK UNDERWATER!
ohh fuck OH FUCK
Where WHERE
Ay yai yai
Ah AHHHHHHH
Ah FUCK I'M DEAD I'M DEAD I ughhh
*sniff*
ughhhhhh
*wtf TIGER talking*
*in between giggles* whhhh WOAH WO HOHOH
WOAH HOHOHOOO
HIYAAA
OOF
oh shit
oh fuck dudee
oh fuck dude
huh HIYA 2x
HIYAA!
HIYAAA!
HI YAAA
HIYA
HIYAA?
*imitating Tiger* They must leave inside my BUTTOCKS
OMNOM
Ohhh Oh ohoh okay
I got THRASH
OHHHH I'M THRASHING
I'M THRASHING SO HARRDDDD
Holy Shit
How do you know that?!
How do you know?!
oohhhhh okay
I seem to be almost dead..
Heh heh *marki laughs*
Oh jeeez. Captain Stubbs can talk to fish!
That's a new revelation! I did not know that!
Okay! Alright then!
Let's carry on. I don't know how to f-
Oh! Break the ceiling. I didn- Didn't know I could do dat!
Didn't didn't know that was possible
Haboosky
I did it! I'm a shark bitch.
Mark the Shark. Comin' thru
Oh I gotta feed!
Heeeeeyy
Eeeee GET SOME!
Woah..
Oh! That's so sad!
Ohh That's - I mean I know its nature and all that but-
Oh my god
I GUESS ITS ALSO SAD THAT HE'S EATING HUMANS BUT-
These poor sealss... :'(
Awww...
Well ... Jeez okay. That's a little -
That's a little OMINOUS don't chu think?
Alright whatever, you know what?
I'm gonna take your word for it
SWOOSH
SABOOSKY
Can I do a sweet- Allrightt yeah look at me
So what am I - What am I catchin' a with of here? (I don't... what?)
Where... where are they?
Oh shit. Oh oh oh gawd Oh god...
WOAHH
ohhh I got dead.
OH!
ohhh...
oh ohhhh
Holy Shit okay...
Use adaptive hide
To hide from s-
Hooo boy
Ya maybe-
Yeah! You'll be back with more GULLIBLE MOROONS that..
..somehow just allow you to-
THROW THEIR LIVES AWAY into the waters.
OKAY! Well.
Did the tutorial!
It was scary as fuck!
AHHH what happens if you actually kill Tony the Tiger Shark?
I dont know...
I don't know but I'm going to try to plaee
I want to be a shark maybe..
uhhh maybe Megalodon Hunt...
I'll try Megalodon Hunt..
okay Alright.
OOKAY Well
Couldn't find a Megalodon Match!
So, I'm just gonna do Quick Play and get another one outta the way and then...
Maybe in the next episode I can actually play with FRIENDS that will wanna kill me...
in every way possible
WOOOOHHHH hehhh fuck
Oh! I'm a diver again
Which means I'm gonna die.
a lot
oh boy okay
k so this time I'm gonna go with-
the Semi-Automatic.
That sounds good. I can do dat.
Alright. I'll ready up.
I'm good! Alright let's do this!
LET'S DO THIS TERRIFYING THING!
let's do this...
What's with the eh five round barrel? That doesn't wh-
Why does a gun have five barrels in it?
That doesn't make any sense
Who designed these guns?!
Does s- z- z- Captain STEVE design these guns and sent us down with his homemade bullshit?!
Oh that guy's got a crown
His name is COCOnut
That's "kandasu3" and a "A GREEN GIRAFFE"
Oh boy we're gonna die
*whisper* ah fuck I hate this game...
I hate this game so much
Ah fuck I hate this game
Hate this game SO much
Oh boy oh boy oh boy
Ho boy ho boy
oohh boy
oh boy
ye ay ay * mark is scareddd*
hoo boy
ho boy
ho boy..
uh oh welp
That's a- that's a-  oohh..
WOOH
WOAWW
WOAHW
OH SHIT
Well didn't get tha-
WAHHHH FUCKING GOD DAMMIT
WOAH HOHHOOHH
WOAHH That one is cold blooded apparently
Ooohh I get it
I get it. I have to collect treasures throughout the game.
WOAH x4
AH FUCKING GOD DAMMIT!
oh JEEEZUS
okay respawn
holy shit,
but at least I got my treasure and I think thats good!
oh wow. that's not good.
*mark is concentration*
oh boy x3
oh missed...
NO I got it! ok I got it!
so this is how you buy stuff. oh I get it okay I got it now
huh eeeh
Alright. Why are we so separated?
It doesn't seem good.
It doesn't seem- AHHHIIII FUCKING GOT YA!
GOT CHA!
Got cha!
Gooottt cha...
G'chaaa
G'cha K'CHOW!
K'CHOW! and G'CHAA
oh boy.
This ain't good
ah.. fucker ducker..
ohh boy
oh these are some- this dangerous this is dangerous this dangerous
ohhhhhh this dangerous
ohhh this so dangerous
hooo thats dangerous
hookay I cashed in my treasure! I GOT A LOT OF MONEYYYY
ooh boy
oh boy
Where're you...
Where you a-holes
Where you dilweeds
okay got bullets wooh
YAIIII YAHHHHHHH
YAHHHH I SAVE YOUUUHHHH
I did that. Woah fuck
What was that. Woah where. wowww... tha'ts not good
Come on, "A GREEN GIRAFFE"
I- I've got chur back. I think...
Not really but- okay.
Again I say that I... AHHH FUCKING GOD DAMMIT
UGHHH
alright okay, but at least I can- I can buyyyy
a~
ri- oh wait no no
sell sell sell
buy THIS
okay yeah I'll do that!
HOOO this seems much better!
seems much beefy better
WOAH fucking
god dammit I lost-
fucken
fucken shit
haha! Gotcha
okay
okay alright
so far so GEEWWWDDD
HO BOY OH BOY (many times)
WHO'S THERE woah
*quietly* who's there
WOAH HELLO
Who's th- AH! f- YOU'RE THERE!
HI! OKAY
oh boy okay
so keep my gunn
ho... AHHHH I SAW YOU GOD DAMMIT!
HO MY GAD
HO STAB I- OHHHH
Ok I need to go get some god damn health...
While they're respawnin'
*drowns*
ehblurgh
ok got it ok I'm doin' okayy
seems like we're down a man but- I don't know where the last guy is
He is all over the place
God I can't see this
wooAHHIIII I see you there!
HAHA! Hahaaaaa
HAHAHAAAA
I need to buy flares...
I need f- I need flares...
Well, that's close
WOAHHKAY
I'M GETTIN' SOME KILLS HERE! I'M DOIN' A LOT BETTER
YOU'RE NOT SO SCARY ANYMOREEE
You're pretty, still pretty damn scary.. but-
oh boy that's not good
shit
gaatcha
okay
hoo boy that was terrifying
oh god I'm almost out of BEWWLETS
*mark is concentration once again*
ho boy, where is that? WHERE IS THAT
OOHHH HEY! NOOO OH MY GOD
There you go. Okay SAVED YOUUUU
Ohhh Ive only got one round left
oh boy (many times)
WAHHHHHHYYY FUCKING
WOOOH BOY
Okay I'm officially out of bullets
That's not good that's not good
oohh ammo over there
yes pleaseee
yes pleasee
hoo boy okay
get my gun out
reloada
ho boy heeeooooo boy where
ga- why is that guy- Why is that guy goin' so farr??
seems like not a smart maneuver
woah
okay. I'M UNSTOPPABLE!
APPARENTLY!
I'VE- I REFUSE TO BE STOPPED EVEN FOR A MOMENT!
HO...
WAAAAYYYYAYYYYY okay
Got youuu
holy fucking SHITTTT
AHHH FUCK
THEY GOT ME X4
fuuuuckkk
ahhhh man I've got so much moneyyy
flaaarresss
mm sea miness x3
sure
k respawn
k I'll put this in the last spo-- AHHHHHH
woahhhhh that was scary
AHHH THATS STILL SCARY
OH GOD
HO MY GOD I CAN'T BELIEVE I MADE IT OUT OF THAT
oh fucking shit thanks for the med kit
bluuu bruu
k I'll put-
put- I'll put sea mines on the-
AHH Fuck me..
hoo fuck me
ho fuck me.
AHH FUCK ME COME ON! THEY'RE AFTER ME!
oh I've- I don't look so good.
The sea mo- the sea mines are not a good look for me.
woah that's not good
ho boy
ooh fuck where is he
AH FUCK
FUCKING AGAIN!?
AHH BOY
come on c'mon we gotta get back in there
AH FUCKN' AGAIN?!
HOHO HOHO SOMEHOW I MADE IT OUT OF THAT ALIVE
gonna get this med kit
haboosky
okay let me play a sea mine right there that's a good place for it
I think I don know
no idea where this asshole's goin'
hooh
What's that guy got, that guy's got a scoodydoo
OOHHH SCOODYDOO
scoodydoo where where where where
holy fuck can't see
ho boy welp that was panic shooting that was a span spray method
I wish I had a FLARE
okay HAIIII
HO BOYY
HEY FUCKING AHHHHHHH
WOAHHOH
I'm alive?!
H- How in do fuck?
oohh that is-
holy shit how the fuck am I alive
BLURGH
Well this prolly not worth it cuz I'm prolly gonna get killed anyway
woah
got ya
hoho! you thought you could hide! I can see you f- for some reason!
woah
where'd he go?
OW!
okay
alright, DIVERS WON!
YEAHHHHH HAHAHHHHH
OH! I HAD THE MOST KILLLS
I DIDN'T GET THE HIGHEST SCORE BUT I GOT THE MOST KILLS
YEAHHHHH
I'VE CONQUERED MY FEARR!
YEAHHH!
AWWW YAYYY HEHE
AHH that's cool
Man, Coconut. Coconut did save us!
*reading* "Be the last player standing against 2 opponents and win the game"
WOAH
That's cool!
Oh that was close! OKAY!
But, either way
That's good
So we only had a certain number of tickets
Eh OH that's what it was.
Oh there are- You can only respawn so many times.
Oh okay
I did not know that
huh
Okay so either way, that is all the time that we have for this episode here.
Thank you so much for watching, in the next episode
I'm gon try play with some friends cuz I wanna try Megalodon Mode
and I wanna try to be a shark *outro music starts playing* and I wanna try to not be terrified in the middle of the ocean
So either way
Thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always
See YOU IN THE NEXT VIDEO!
BAI BAI! :D